[Musique]
bonjour Nour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes avec nous pour la
sortie de votre livre tout ce coupable
ils m'ont marier de force aux éditions
Balan un témoignage bouleversant dans
lequel vous mettez en avant votre combat
de femme marié de force à votre cousin à
l'âge de 18 ans la violence est
l'insensibilité de votre famille envers
vous je précise que vous avez des
regarder l'anonymat pour votre sécurité
voilà merci en tout cas pour votre
confiance merci beaucoup
alors vous avez grandi dans une fratrie
de 7 enfants d'une famille originaire du
nord du Maroc
vous parlez d'une famille très
traditionnaliste avec des coutumes du
site farfelu
au collège vous n'aviez pas le droit de
sortir de chez vous
et dans le livre vous racontez cette
fois où vous avez été insulté battu
jusqu'au sang et séquestré par votre
mère pour être resté devant le collège
le de rentrer à la maison
ce que vous pouvez peut-être me dire
comment vous avez vécu cette privation
de liberté
c'était dur très dur
je ne comprenais pas
d'un côté je me disais que c'était
normal c'était comme ça partout
mais non
non
et vous êtes rendu compte aussi
peut-être avec vos amis en France que
justement d'autres familles étaient
différents qui avait plus de liberté
aussi avec des amis que vous aviez
peut-être au lycée
vous avez réussi à tout à fait découvrir
que votre famille du coup c'était
c'était vraiment différent
je pensais que c'était eux qui étaient
bizarre qui
m'a en fait contre moi c'était
chez moi dans ma famille
et en fait pour votre famille votre
votre destin était déjà tracé
vous étiez élevé pour être une bonne
cuisine hier comme vous dites une femme
à tout faire et malgré tout vous dites
que tout ça a été normal pour vous vous
sentiez comme une esclave vous étiez
parfois privé de repas aussi
malgré tout malgré les coûts vous
continuez d'aimer votre famille
c'était c'était un repère pour vous
et vous écrivez la violence a été
l'amour comme apporté
est-ce qu'avec le recul vous pouvez
expliquer peut-être comment vous avez
réussi à garder cet amour envers votre
votre famille
c'est complexe
mais j'ai du mal à
couper les ponts à me dire que
je pouvais pas partir je pouvais pas
malgré aussi malgré la violence malgré
les coups c'était comme vous dites c'est
un repère pour vous
je pensais que c'était par tout comme ça
c'était
c'était une façon d'éduquer
et puis aussi cette fois vous quand vous
étiez jeune vous vouliez aider les
autres vous avez fait ce stage à maison
de retraite
vous êtes occupé vous êtes occupé des
personnes âgées
et comme vous vous occupez de votre
grand-mère aussi est-ce que peut-être
vous pouvez parler de cette relation
vous avez très forte avec votre
grand-mère
si tu es une femme formidable
si la seule qui a pu me donner un peu de
temps de ça plus d'amour
[Musique]
considéré comme ma mère
c'est elle était ma force
avec votre grand-mère des moments forts
en parlant des femmes berbères
à la femme
et c'est là qui me tenait des conseils
en disant
devient quelqu'un
ne laisse personne te dire de quoi faire
quoi dire
et sois forte
c'est
la femme qui est plus de recul sur sur
les choses peut-être par rapport à
d'autres femmes comme votre mère aussi
qui était plus dans les traditions et
dans les dans les coutumes m'expliquer
que ma mère avait été mariée de force
aussi elle elle n'avait pas son mot à
dire
dans la famille dans cette tribu
et elle m'avait mis en garde quand même
qu'est-ce qui a fait que votre
grand-mère elle a eu un regard différent
sur sur les hommes qu'elle s'est
beaucoup plus méfier peut-être
la violence le truc
et puis à l'âge de 18 ans vous apprenez
par votre cousine que votre cousin
marocain voulait demander votre main
on vous explique que c'était comme ça
dans la famille on se marie contre nous
et lors des vacances au Maroc juste
avant votre retour en France
votre père vous a imposé un mariage avec
cet homme comment est-ce que vous avez
vécu cette ce moment
j'ai été trahi
je pense que je ne réalisais pas non
plus
des choses à ce moment-là
ou vraiment là où ça m'a vraiment ouvert
les yeux c'est qu'on va emmener chez le
médecin
me faire un certificat
et puis voilà j'essaye tout le monde
j'ai écouté une demi-sœur qui me disait
de le faire semblant de et arriver en
France
mais j'ai confiance
[Musique]
en fait même si les papiers je ne savais
même pas ce que je signais je ne savais
même pas que c'était pour faire le
enclencher la procédure
[Musique]
je précise quand vous parlez de
certificat vous parlez du certificat de
virginité c'est ça donc le médecin vous
a dit que voilà votre père et votre
tuteur c'est lui qui voulait imposer
donc vous pouvez rien faire je n'avais
pas le choix voilà de force même si vous
refusez
et alors
ce moment qui est terrible une fois que
vous retournez en France votre famille a
dû partir au Maroc pour s'occuper votre
de votre grand-mère qui était souffrante
et là vous décrivez la violence terrible
et cruelle de votre cousin qui était
venu en France
vous étiez seul avec lui dans
l'appartement familial
cet homme vous a violé insulté il a même
filmé l'axe en disant que vous lui
appartenir
et malgré les appels à l'aide auprès de
votre famille personne ne vous croyez et
cet homme est accueilli comme un roi
comment comment vous expliquer le fait
que votre parole n'avait pas
d'importance vis-à-vis de cet homme
je suis une femme on ne croit pas la
femme c'est l'homme qui
chez les rois qui décide qui
va pas pouvoir sur la femme
et votre mère non plus mais vous écoutez
pas par rapport à ce sujet et vous
disiez que vous n'étiez pas normal vous
écrivez dans le livre elle me rétorka
que c'était mon mari et que je devais me
taire
est-ce que peut-être vous pouvez nous
dire est-ce que votre mère a eu quand
même des gestes de tendresse envers vous
malgré malgré tout ça non
et faire ce qu'il avait à faire
activité même pas question de remettre
la parole de l'homme en question en fait
non
j'ai essayé de lui dire j'ai
et honnêtement j'ai pas pu lui dire
qu'il m'avait violé
les accusations qui me portaient à mon
encontre j'avais peur
alors évidemment à partir de là vous ne
supportez plus le regard des hommes sur
vous c'est ce qu'on peut évidemment
comprendre
est-ce que est-ce qu'après ce qui vous
est arrivé vous arrivez encore à faire
confiance
avoir confiance envers les hommes
comment ça se passe au quotidien je sais
pas par exemple dans votre travail je
sais pas si on peut en parler c'est très
difficile c'est difficile j'ai dû
changer de travail
arrivé beaucoup d'hommes ou je me
sentais pas bien
je me sentais mal étouffé
et j'avais l'impression de revoir
[Musique]
peut-être de venir plus général avec les
gens en général parce que
est-ce que voilà est-ce que vous arrivez
aussi à faire confiance avec les mêmes
les femmes aussi de manière générale
non
j'évite de parler de quoi que ce soit de
mur en fait
mais c'est vraiment pour me protéger
c'est
je ne veux même pas qu'on puisse voir
quoi que ce soit moi
et même voilà tout ce que vous décrivez
dans le livre est-ce que vous arrivez à
en parler quand même à certaines
personnes
mon thérapeute j'ai pas pu lui dire
je lui ai fait lire
il y a des celles que je n'y arrive pas
ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas possible
c'est
j'ai honte en fait
je me dis ma famille va me croire
encore aujourd'hui vous avez du mal à
vous sentez encore coupable vous le
dites des fois vous me l'avez dit
antenne vous me demandiez si vous étiez
coupable de quoi que ce soit encore
aujourd'hui vous trouvez vous avez des
doutes là-dessus
je me dis j'ai forcément fait quelque
chose
pour en arriver là pour
et pourtant j'ai toujours été droite
j'ai toujours
alors pendant cette période après ce
après ce viol évidemment vous alliez peu
en cours et votre peur votre père
voulait des explications
et votre cousin disait que vous étiez
une mauvaise femme qu'il regrettait de
vous avoir épousé et il vous a donné une
réputation de prostituées auprès de
votre famille comment comment vous avez
vécu aussi ce moment
j'ai essayé de lui dire à mon père qui
m'avait enfermé
on a des jours
que c'était un fou que c'était
on écoutait pas c'est
j'ai l'impression que c'était vraiment
moi
aussi ce moment où à l'hôpital vous
allez pour des problèmes de santé et le
médecin vous apprend que vous êtes
enceinte de votre cousin
vous aviez le sentiment de porter
l'enfant du diable
et vous parlez dans le livre de la de la
culpabilité de cet avortement vous avez
dû faire est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
davantage par rapport à ça
j'ai fait quelque chose de grave
je pense que je n'avais pas le choix
c'est
si mon cousin le risque
soit une nourriture soit je serai encore
avec lui de force
ici il apprend que j'ai avorté de son
enfant et
il est capable de tout
mais oui
je pouvais pas mettre au monde un enfant
oui j'ai fait quelque chose de grave oui
[Musique]
que ce soit interdit dans la religion
musulmane
et ensuite il y a eu l'instance de
divorce avec votre cousin
c'était une ombre dans votre famille
vous avez subi le rejet vous adressez
plus la parole et vous avez découvert le
jour du mariage que votre sœur est née
se marier avec ce même cousin
votre mère vous a même dit que vous
aviez laissé tomber un homme bien et que
votre aîné avait de la chance
comment est-ce que vous vous avez vécu
ce moment où vous avez découvert que
votre
cousin se remarier du coup avec votre
serez né
à plusieurs reprises
et pourtant cette science
avec elle
donc je gardais ses enfants donc je lui
ai demandé de l'aide
et à la fin du livre vous dites qui
écrire ça a été votre thérapie vous
n'aviez plus que votre plume comme ami
vous écrivez dans le livre
qu'est-ce que ça a présenté d'écrire ce
livre pour vous
beaucoup de choses
honnêtement je pensais pas être encore
encore là au jour d'aujourd'hui
quand j'ai écrit
mon histoire c'est je pensais vraiment à
me
mettre ma vie
j'ai envoyé tout ça ma meilleure amie
pour le Sintra c'est
vous avez mis combien de temps écrire ce
livre
deux trois jours
ça c'est vraiment faire très rapidement
oui
[Musique]
une grande difficulté à écrire ça se
fait sur plusieurs mois j'écris
[Musique]
une preuve de ce qui s'est passé de
ce que je me disais que s'il me l'a fait
à moi un jour il
[Musique]
et au moins j'aurais pu détailler tout
il y a eu des passages j'imagine plus
difficile que d'autres à écrire
je me suis dit c'est petit détail
pouvait faire
est-ce que ça nous avons enlevé un poids
vous êtes senti libéré un peu plus
libérée en tout cas après après
l'écriture
un petit peu
alors dans le livre vous écrivez aussi
voilà une partie de moi est fière de mon
cœur car il a été détruit brûlé écrasé
brisé et il bat toujours
ce que peut-être vous pouvez nous dire
comment vous vous sentez aujourd'hui
je souris beaucoup plus qu'avant
mais je garde des conseils encore
est-ce que aujourd'hui vous avez encore
des relations avec votre famille
de prénom
de loin oui
avec ma mère
j'essaie de prendre des nouvelles
pour voir
il ne reste
je ne suis pas la bienvenue
et par rapport à tout ça votre mère
enfin est-ce qu'elle a réussi à
comprendre certaines choses par rapport
à vous aussi
je pense qu'elle a compris que c'est
vraiment quelque chose c'est vraiment
pas quelque chose de grave
[Musique]
en tout cas les relations que vous avez
aujourd'hui voilà c'est vous ne vous
rencontrez plus physiquement en tout cas
c'est plus possible pour vous
j'ai essayé
de couper les ponts avec sa famille
et à me répéter sans cesse
comme moi comment je peux lui répéter
bah le mariage forcé dans la religion
et elle me dit tout oublier
il faut avancer avec ma sœur que ils ont
eu des enfants
tu dois accepter
ou par rapport à ces questions là elle a
pas évolué non plus enfin non pour elle
c'était
que beaucoup de femmes le vivent
plus de gestes de tendresse envers vous
peut-être par téléphone est-ce que
elle essaye avec mon enfant
mais
je ne lui serai jamais mon enfant
je peux être méchante en disant ça mais
on m'a vraiment détruite c'est
elle n'a jamais été là quand j'avais
besoin d'elle quand je lui ai demandé de
l'aide
quand je lui ai montré les traces
et justement vous en parler aujourd'hui
vous avez un mari vous avez un enfant
avec ce mari aussi
c'est eux qui vous donne la force
d'avancer aussi oui quel est le message
que vous voudriez faire passer aux
femmes qui qui vivent parce que vous
avez vécu
adoré et ne pas se taire
ne pas avoir honte
ne pas se sentir coupable surtout
surtout pas
merci beaucoup merci pour pour ce
témoignage que vous avez livré
aujourd'hui merci et pour pour ce livre
que vous avez écrit
merci infiniment à vous
[Musique]